In a speech before the
Virginia secession convention
in 1861 late April,
the wake of the firing on Fort Sumpter,
the newly elected sort of appointed
vice president of the confederacy,
Alexander H.
Stephens gave a speech that became quickly
known to history as his cornerstone
speech.
Yeah,
this is spring 1861 Alexander
aches Stevens, a Georgian,
a slave holder,
old friend and colleague of
Abraham Lincoln's ironically
said the cornerstone of
the confederacy,
the cornerstone of their political
movement was what he called American Negro
slavery.
It was the cornerstone on which
they had founded their revolution.
The quote goes on as a race,
the African is inferior to the white man.
Subordination to the white
man is his normal condition.
He is not his equal by nature and
cannot be made so by human laws or human
institutions. Our system, therefore,
so far as regards to this inferior race,
rests upon this great
immutable law of nature.
You always have to get worried in history
when people start to start talking
about
how human beings or human behavior
is rooted in nature.
But how do we get to 1861 and that's
the session crisis with Alexander Age.
Steven's delivering this
cornerstone speech, declaring that,
hey folks, it's all about
slavery and its preservation.
How did we get there today I want to
talk about, we're going to dwell on
ultimately the southern
defense of slavery.
The argument's over time that
they develop layer upon layer,
drawing upon earlier arguments,
building them into new ones,
sometimes quite original toward old,
toward ultimately a virtually utopian
defense of slavery as a perfecting
perfectible if not perfected system.
Now I want to say one of the quick
thing before we get to the substance.
1,000 times in a thousand ways,
anybody who studies the American
civil war period is inevitably ass.
Okay?
So what caused this war?
So of course the question of
the first third of this course.
So what caused it
yesterday on ml king day,
I had the privilege of being on the least
for radio programs about this new book
I wrote called the slave no more.
Some of them quite terrific. Uh,
Minnesota public radio does
a fabulous hour long program,
but one of them was on a Nashville,
Tennessee radio station on a program
at 5:30 PM called drive time.
And the host was Harry or peach or whoever
he was. I'd been on too many of these.
First question was, so, professor,
what was the civil war about?
Now do that in a soundbite on Nashville
radio station when you got two minutes
to answer. Well, Pete, you see, uh,
there was this free labor
system in the slave labor
system, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I tried to sound byte this and I ended
up saying something silly like, you know,
Pete,
I'm teaching a whole course on this.
Yeah.
And I finally just ended that particular
little exchange before he went on to
rant at me about what all is wrong
with American education by saying Pete.
Uh,
it was slavery
and Alexis de Tocqueville's
great democracy in America,
which you published in 1831 or a Polish
name 37 after his famous nine month tour
of the United States,
the most famous book travel book ever
written about America by a foreigner.
And democracy in America.
There's that famous passage or passages
on Tocqueville crosses the Ohio River
from Ohio in the Kentucky from free soil
and the slave soil free state into a
slave state talk.
People you may know didn't spend a great
deal of time in the south though he
traveled all across the south,
spent oh at least two thirds of is more
than about three quarters of his time in
the northern states,
but when he crossed into Kentucky,
he wrote this letter to his
father for the first time.
This is of course the French
Aristocrat de Tocqueville.
For the first time we have had the
chance to examine the effect that slavery
produces on a society on
the right bank of the Ohio.
Everything is activity.
Industry. Labor is honored.
There are no slaves pass to the
left bank and the scene changes.
So suddenly that you think yourself
on the other side of the world,
the enterprising spirit seems gone.
Their work is not only painful,
it's shameful and you degrade yourself
and submitting yourself to it.
To ride, to hunt, to smoke
like a Turk isn't a song.
It's a thing like a Turk in the sunshine.
There's the destiny of the white man to
do any other kind of manual labor is to
act like a slave.
Okay.
Now,
Tocqueville was of course responding
from his own kind of French aristocratic
heart to some extent.
He was drawn in a bit to certain
kinds of southern charm. The whites,
he said of the south form
a veritable aristocracy,
which combines many prejudices
with high sentiments and instincts.
He probably over judged the
scale of that aristocracy.
Yeah.
They say,
and I am much inclined to beliefs that
Tocqueville that in the matter of honor,
these men practice, delicacies and
refinements unknown in the north.
They are frank,
hospitable and put many
things before money.
Oh,
they'd love that.
When we start hearing from our
pro slavery advocates and writers,
they would have loved that because one
of the critiques that slavery allowed
pro-slavery writers ultimately to make
was a critique of a certain kind of
capitalism, the greedy,
grinding, aggressive,
malicious kind of capitalism.
They believed the north body,
but charm alone didn't seem to make a
great society. According to Tocqueville,
you see few churches and no
schools here in the south.
He observed society like the
individual seems to provide nothing.
The south would end.
He said by being dominated by the north
every day the latter grows more wealthy
and densely populated while the south
is stationary and growing poor and not
entirely accurate about that either
from what we now know about the
profitability of slavery and
profitability of the cotton crop,
but he ends that famous
section with this passage.
It is kind of haunting when you think
it's only 1831 when he writes this and
that civil war is still 30 years away.
Slavery,
brutalizes the black population and
debilitates the white man is not made for
servitude.
Now
in the south,
what developed,
and let's define it at least quickly,
what developed was one of the world's
handful of true slave societies.
What is a slave society?
What do we mean when we use
that phrase slave society?
Essentially it means any society
where slave labor or the
definition of labor, where the,
where the definition of the relationship
between ownership and labor is defined
by slavery by a cradle to grave.
And some would have even said a cradle
to grave and beyond human bondage or
slavery affected everything about society
were whites and blacks in this case in
America,
in a racialized slavery system grew up,
we're socialized by married rear children,
worked,
invested in and conceived of the idea
of property and home their most basic
habits and values under the influence
of a system that said it was just to own
people as property.
The other slave societies
in human history.
And you can get up a real
debate over this, uh,
especially among Africanists,
Brazilian east Asianist and others.
And it's why slavery is such a hot
field and in international history,
but the other great slave societies in
history where the whole social structure
of those societies was rooted in
slavery or ancient Greece and Rome,
certainly Brazil by the
18th and 19th century,
the whole of the Caribbean,
the Great West indies,
sugar producing empires of the French.
The British, the Dutch, the
Spanish, and a few others,
and the American south.
Now
there were other localized slave society,
surely,
certainly within Africa
to a certain degree,
even before Europeans arrived and
certainly after Europeans arrived,
particularly after the regularization
of the Atlantic slave trade,
there were certain localized slave
societies in east Africa out of Zanzibar.
By the 18th and 19th century,
there were certain localized slave
societies in the vast Arab world and the
Muslim world,
uh,
well before there was even an
Atlantic slave trade to the Americans.
The five great slave societies
were those fine. Yeah.
All we're highly
profitable in their primes.
All tended to hinder technological
innovation in those societies.
All tended to have a high slave
to free ratio of population.
All of those slave societies had a
population of slaves that was from one
quarter to one half and sometimes
more of the total population.
Okay.
In those slave societies,
slaves as an interest,
as an interest.
Okay.
We're both a political and
a great economic institution
that defined
ways of life.
Now
when exactly did the American south
become a slave society? You know, is it
1820 the Missouri crisis
in that settlement and at
least the beginnings now of
of a clarity of its expansion or was it
more the 1830s when you got this booming
cotton production happening finally and
Alabama and Mississippi and Louisiana?
Or was it 1840 or was it really in the
wake of the Mexican war when you get this
massive expansion into the the great
southwest and the Mexican session,
which will take up actually next week.
That's,
that's always open to debate exactly
when the south became a slave society,
but I think it became in most ways and
in most definitions of slave societies,
surely by the 1820s or the 30s now
one aspect of that slave society.
Then I'll focus on it
just at least briefly
is that as Americans ended the foreign
slave trade and we did an 1808 this is,
this month is the bicentennial of the
legal end of America's participate in
United States participation
in the foreign slave trade.
I didn't entirely in and there were
some south Carolinians and Georgians who
wanted to reopen it and a few folks out
in Louisiana who wanted to reopen it.
It numerous times in
the antebellum periods,
especially in the late 1850s
there were the same people.
We're always trying to annex
Cuba about four times over.
They tried to annex Cuba and it's still
a bit of a mystery how it never happened,
but as the foreign slave trade was closed
off for a whole variety of reasons,
only one of which was that there was this
passage sort of a vow and the original
constitution that the question would
be revisited in 20 years in 1808 was 20
years.
Okay.
But as the foreign
slave trade was cut off,
the domestic American slave
trade absolutely boomed.
And one the reasons that the American
south could become such a profitable slave
society.
One of the reasons that the cotton boom
could be the cotton boom is because,
yeah.
One of the unique features
of North American slavery,
US s slavery is,
or was that it was the only slave
population in the entire new world.
Brazil managed to now and then,
but not in the long run.
It's the only slave society in,
in the new world or the slaves
naturally reproduce themselves.
That has to do with climate, that has
to do with sex ratio, male to female.
It has to do with diet and
it has to do with movement.
If Frederick Jackson Turner had
anything right and the frontier thesis,
so the hidden apparently
any attention to the south,
this idea of a safety
valve of a west to move to,
we're surely there for slavery
between 1810 and 1820 alone.
This is the decade of the war of 1812
which caused all kinds of chaos on the
western frontier.
137,000 American slaves were forced
to move from North Carolina or the
Chesapeake states to Alabama,
Mississippi,
and other western regions.
That's in the one decade of the teens.
Okay.
Then from 1820 to 1860 the 40 years
before the war and estimated roughly 2
million American slaves were sold to
satisfy the need of slave labor in the
great cotton kingdom.
Okay.
Of the growing South West?
No.
About roughly two thirds of those 2
million slaves move from the eastern
seaboard or the upper south to Alabama,
Louisiana,
Mississippi, Texas, Arkansas, et cetera.
About two thirds of those
went by outright sale
by financial speculation and now a
growing huge American business of the
domestic slave trade.
By the 1830 [inaudible] 1840 [inaudible],
there were over 100 men in Charleston,
South Carolina alone making their
livings fulltime as slave traders.
Okay.
Their ads were in the
newspapers every day,
okay.
Many of them own their own shops and their
own in effect jails where they housed
people.
Other cities became major ports
are places of deportation.
Okay.
For the domestic slave trade,
Richmond, Virginia, for example,
became a huge slave trading center,
uh,
by the 1840 [inaudible] and 1850s,
it had two depending on when you look
to three dozen major fulltime slave
traders. One of the richest
was a man named Hector Davis.
Hector Davis owned a two stories slave
auction house in jail on 14th and
Franklin streets' just two blocks down
the hill from Thomas Jefferson's glorious
Capitol building of the State of Virginia.
Just two blocks down the hill from
that great equestrian statue of George
Washington,
the founder,
you could find a huge slave
jail owned by Hector Davis.
Fector Davis kept tremendous records.
He kept the account books,
huge account books.
One of those account books ended up in
the Chicago historical society after the
civil war because it was confiscated by
an Illinois regiment that took it home.
And I worked with that
account book because one of
the two slaves I write about
and this new book called a
slave no more published there.
Two narratives was indeed a young 14
year old teenagers sold out of North
Carolina, uh, from Snow
Hill, North Carolina.
He was sold 1960 to
Hector Davis in Richmond.
Actor Dave purchased him for
$900 for about six months.
Wallace turnage worked in Hector Davis,
a slave auction house,
helping organize the auctions every day.
And one day the Wallace was told today,
boy,
you're in the auction.
And he was sold for $1,000 to an Alabama
cotton planner who came up to Richmond
twice a year to buy slaves
and 72 hours by train.
He found himself on a huge cotton
plantation. And your Pickens Ville,
Alabama on the UN in West Central
Alabama on the Mississippi border.
Yeah,
at 14 years old.
Okay.
Martin Wireless Turner's
later in the course, he, he'll
be sold again, by the way,
a third time for $2,000 in mobile,
Alabama that the at the mobile slave
jail I calculated and Hector Davis,
his account book at the biggest weak
he had and he had some big weeks,
but he had a week in 1859 where he made
a cool approximately $120,000 in profit
just from selling slave.
I mean the equivalent of a of
a healthy teenage male slave.
If you could sell them
for $1,000 in 1861 up.
It's about the same price of
a good Toyota Camry today.
And when I go to the Aon Toyota for
my service or to buy my new Camry,
which I've done every four
years for the last two decades,
I don't always think of a slave
market, but it does occur to me. But
yeah,
they just sell those
Toyota's that they tell you.
Here's the price we don't bargain.
Okay.
The south was part of
the westward movement
for slave children.
One of the little point about this so we
can get a sense of this system that is
now about to be justified and for slave
children between eight and 20 and 1860
living in the upper south
or the eastern seaboard.
They had approximately a 30% chance
of being sold outright away from their
parents before they were 10
now,
just to give you a sense of how cold and
calculated this business was and how in
many ways the first defense
or justification of of
slavery in America is of
course it's certainly is by
the late antebellum period.
It is an unabashed economic defense.
As we'll see
ads and newspapers like this one in
Charleston would read Negros wanted,
I am paying the highest cash prices
for young and likely negroes.
Those having good front teeth
and being otherwise sound.
It's all about market forces and the
health and the condition of your product.
Probably the best book written on this,
particularly on the language of the
domestic slave trade is Walter Johnson's
book called soul by soul book.
I highly recommend you read it
sometime and were reading lives,
but it's amazing to read the letters in
the language of slave traders when they
write to each other.
The complacency,
the mixture of,
of,
of just pure racism on the one hand and
just business language on the other.
I refused a girl 20 years
old at $700 yesterday,
one trade or wrote to another in 1853 if
you think best to take her at 700 I can
still get her. She is very badly
whipped but has good teeth.
Bought a cook.
Yesterday I wrote another trader bought
a cook yesterday that was to go out of
the state. She just made
the people mad. That was all
I have bought.
A boy named Isaac wrote another trader
for $1,100 he writes to this in 1854 to
his partner,
bought a boy named Isaac
I think in very prime.
He is a house servant,
first rate cook and
splendid carriage driver.
He is also a fine painter and varnish
shirt and says he can make a fine panel
door. Also, he performs
well on the violin.
He is a genius and it's strange to
say I think he's smarter than I am.
Yeah,
truth always creeps through all
of our language. Doesn't always,
but sometimes creeps through our language,
doesn't it?
Now,
how has slavery defended
in many ways to say the least,
but I want to give you at
least some sense of the,
the development of the pro
slavery argument of the
kinds of arguments that were
used, how they changed over
time. Who made the argument
now
the best way to begin to understand pro
slavery ideology or whether we're in the
early period of its defense in the 1820s
we're actually a quite vigilant defense
of slavery begins early.
It isn't something that just sprung from
southern pins and the 1850s during all
this expansion.
It comes very early,
but a framework in which done to standard
is it pro slavery ideology was at its
heart a kind of deeply conservative,
organic world view,
and by that I mean a
Berkey and conservatism,
a set of beliefs that says the world
is ordered as it is for reasons
and then human beings ought not
tinker with that order very much.
It was a set of beliefs in the
sustenance of a social order as it is.
Okay.
It was a belief in a hierarchical
conception of not only society,
but if people that people were conceived,
whether by nature or by
God or even by evolution.
Okay,
well a certain order to them.
So I'm born to do this. Yes,
I'm born to do that and
some born to do that.
It's an organic conception of the world.
It just is the way it is.
It's natural.
Remember back to Alexander H.
Stevens cornerstone quote.
He uses the word natural
twice in that pasture.
This worldview had, of course,
an obsession was stability.
Okay.
It's one of the reasons white
southerners didn't like reformers.
It's one of the reasons abolitionists,
they're dangerous.
What are abolition is calling
for upsetting the social order.
They're offering a critique of
the social order and they're even,
they even have the audacity
to talk about good and evil.
It's just, it's a worldview often
obsessed, as we said last time,
what notions of honor and duty,
and it's a worldview deeply rooted
in the idea or for tradition,
tradition and social
control and this worldview,
institutions,
human institutions evolve only slowly
over time and cannot be altered.
Why? Abrupt human
interventions? It's dangerous,
too abruptly intervene in the
evolution of human institutions.
I think what's at stake
here in this world view,
especially as we transition next Thursday
to a developing though by no means
unanimous or homogenous northern
worldview in which reform impulses get
embedded.
Okay.
White southern defenders of slavery.
We're to some extent like other
Americans products of the enlightenment.
Yeah.
Some of them come to really
believe in intellect.
They really do come to believe in the
power of reason though human beings to
figure out the universe.
Yeah.
But to figure it out in different ways.
You can be a product of the enlightenment
and still be deeply conservative.
Yeah.
You can be a product of the enlightenment
and with the faith and reason and not
become a romantic well begins to believe
in the possibilities of man or even the
perfectibility of man
conservative as conservativism deep
organic forms of conservative activism is
not antithesis,
is not antithetical to the enlightenment
and he's not entirely Arlo pro slavery
writers will become deeply,
uh,
contemptuous of natural law of natural
law doctrine as it can be applied to the
possibilities of man.
Okay.
Many of them will argue therefore that
ideas like freedom and I that idea of
liberties so much at stake in the age of
the American revolution and falling off
everybody's tongue and eventually falling
off of their tongues and off their
pens as well.
Yeah.
What they're fighting for by
1861 where their liberties,
they said over and over
and over and over again,
but in their worldview,
the pro slavery worldview,
he's like freedom and liberty
were simply never. Absolutely.
Okay.
And many of them will directly reverse
Thomas Jefferson's declaration of
independence and simply say,
nobody is born equal.
Okay.
They will argue over
and over and over again.
Some of them almost in a feudalistic way,
that freedom must always be balanced
with order and that order is rooted in
certain kinds,
prescribes stations in life
for the various statuses of humans
or freedom, they will argue
must be balanced with tradition.
The possibilities of freedom must always,
in their view,
be balanced with the world as
it is not as it ought to be.
Yeah.
They are therefore going to have an
extremely different point of view from at
least abolitionists in the north
and this concept of equality.
Although a lot of abolitionists had
their struggles with this one too.
Southern pro slavery defenders are much
more likely to stress a human's duty
then there ever distress a humans rights.
They believe that the world was made up
of a struggle between human autonomy on
the one hand and human
dependency on the other,
and you should never give up on that.
Dependency
is early as 1826 and important pro-slavery
writer name Edward Brown argued that
slavery, he said, quote,
had ever been the stepping ladder by which
nations have passed from barbarism to
civilization.
There you have the roots in the kernel
of the so called positive good thesis
about slavery,
but slavery was a way in which
you sustained a social order,
a way in which you built an economy,
a way in which you maximize the
possibilities of those who deserved it
by using those who did not deserve.
Okay.
The same fruits.
Pro Slavery Writers, you have to
understand outhouse. So it really, uh,
often a fundamentally different conception
of history itself or how history
happens.
Then we'll many eventually
northern antislavery writers,
even eventually the political antislavery
folks like an Abraham Lincoln.
It was never a real abolition is but
did at least grow up with antislavery in
his heart.
Yeah.
Thomas are do very important pro-slavery
writer who wrote a whole book in the
wake of the state of Virginia's debates
in 1830 and 32 or 30 and 31 31 32 over
whether to rewrite its constitution and
they squared the faced the question of a
gradual abolition plan for the
of Virginia in 1831 and 32,
they had been planning to
rewrite their constitution.
Extraordinary turning
point in southern history.
The problem was of course
nat Turner's insurrection.
It just occurred in October of 1831 and
they held these debates in the wake of
it and do wrote a forceful defense
of slavery in the wake of this,
which became kind of a,
a seminal text for all future pro slavery
writers among the many things he said.
And that was this simple
sense of how history happens.
There is a time for all things wrote,
do,
and nothing in this world
should be done before its time.
And what would you do if
your parents told you that
they probably have?
What would you do if your professors
told you that all the time?
Stop trying to change things.
Nothing will change before it's time.
You'll probably get bored
or angry or who knows?
Maybe you would just agree.
I don't know.
Youth are supposed to be impatient
now.
Um,
there are many ways to
look at pro slavery,
deep,
and the pro slavery argument.
I'm going to give you categories
here to hang your hats on.
Deepened the pro slavery
argument is a biblical argument.
Almost all pro slavery writers at one
point or another will dip into the Old
Testament or dip into the new testament.
They, especially with dip to the old,
to show how slavery is an ancient
and venerable institution.
It's venerability was its own argument.
Some set, it's always been around.
Every civilization has had it.
All those biblical societies had it.
You can read Jeremiah and Isaiah and some
of the Great Old Testament prophets in
some ways as defenders of slavery.
Okay?
You can therefore assume
it was divinely sanctioned.
You can also look in the New Testament
for examples of it, justifications of it.
Slaves be out, be honorable,
be be dutiful, be obedient.
It's usually the word in the King James
Slaves. Be Obedient to your masters.
Slavery's all over the Bible
and one way or another,
the Bible of course can
breathe antislavery into a
situation and it can breathe
pro slavery into a situation.
Okay.
A second kind of set of arguments I've
already referred to are the historical
ones. Here it is not just
the venerability of slavery,
how old it is,
but it's the idea that it has been
crucial to development of all great
civilizations.
That slavery may have its bad aspects,
but it has been the creek,
the engine of good.
It has been the engine of empires, the
engine of wealth, the engine of greatness.
How would you have had Cicero?
How would you have had the great
Roman philosophers and thinkers?
How would you have had the
great Greek playwrights?
They would argue without the system,
the world,
the Greeks were able to
create with the hell lots,
but at the base of all societies,
there has to be a labor system that
will support the possibility of Plato.
Yeah.
Personally,
radiology is also,
yeah,
part of, at the same time, it's
resistant to the greatest product,
arguably, of the enlightenment, and
that is the idea of natural rights,
natural law and natural rights,
rights by birth rights from
God being born with certain
capacities.
I personally, every writers were
inspired by this to some extent,
but many of them will simply convert it.
They will convert it.
They'll take portions of John Locke
that they like and not the others.
And they'll say the real rule of
the world is not natural equality,
but it is natural inequality.
Humans are not all born the
same with the same capacities,
abilities.
Now
then there's a whole array of
economic arguments and the cynic,
the economic determinists simply goes to
the economic conclusions of pro slavery
and nowhere else.
Um,
one of the greatest of these
writers was James Henry Hammond,
South Carolina planner who had
plenty of mixed race children.
He was in some ways the epitome of
the kind of cynical pro slavery.
And the end of the day he
wasn't bothered by morality.
His argument for slavery was
that it ultimately it was amoral.
But at the end of the day,
he also essentially made a property
argument or a property defense of slavery.
He wrote, among other
things, the means, therefore,
whatever they may have been by which the
African race now in this country have
been reduced to slavery,
cannot affect us since
they are our property.
As your land is your property by
inheritance or purchase and prescriptive,
right? You'll, we'll say that
man cannot hold property in man.
The answer is that he can and actually
does hold property in his fellow all over
the world in a variety of
forms and has always done so.
Thank you. Very much. Said Henry Hammond.
Don't talk to me about property in man.
Oh, some would get
guilty. Indeed they did.
Some would get worried and then we'll
discuss slavery as a necessary evil.
This system entailed upon them.
God, they wish they were without it.
And some of them, frankly, folks
were deeply sincere in that.
One of the most famous and one of the
most prolific was a man named Charles Cold
Cock Jones,
who owned a huge rice and partly cotton
plantation system in low country,
Georgia, just south of
Savannah. He and his family, uh,
wrote literally thousands
upon thousands of letters.
Those family letters have been published
in a book called the children of pride.
And a brilliant book has been written
about Cold Cock Jones in his extended
family by ors can Clark
called dwelling place.
But one of the fascinating things about
Charles coldcocked Jones born in the
late 18th century, uh, rises through
adulthood by the teens. 1820s
is he's a classic example of the
highly educated southern planter.
He came north, he was educated
in theology at Yale for a while.
He was really affected by it.
And then he went up to and
over a theological academy
and he taught there and
he's affected even more by
New England theologians.
And he began to write back first to his
fiance, who quickly became his wife Mary.
And he was really worried about
all slaves heal. He writes,
for example,
to marry,
I am moreover undecided whether I
ought to continue to hold slaves.
He underlines hold slaves as to the
principle of slavery. It is wrong.
It is unjust, contrary to nature
and religion to hold men and slave.
But the question is,
in my present circumstances with evil
on my hands and tailed from my father,
would the general interest of the slaves
and community at large with reference
to the slaves be promoted
best by emancipation?
Could I do more for the ultimate good
of the slave population by holding or
emancipating what I own.
I know not very particularly
how you feel on this point,
and there are many letters like that.
He and his wife right back and
forth about how evil slavery is,
but in the end,
cold cock,
John's becomes a classic example of
the guilty pro slavery slave holder.
He doesn't know how to freeze him.
He doesn't know how to go to emancipation.
Instead,
he developed a highly intricate theory
of how he's going to use slavery to save
black people.
He's going to ameliorate their conditions.
He's going to make their slavery on
his plantations so effective, so good,
such a
even joyous form of labor that he will
be doing God's work by improving slavery.
It's a, it's a genuinely tragic
sort of story. In his case,
there are plenty of pro slavery
writers who also to some extent,
whether out of guilt or out of
awareness saw slavery is wrong,
but they saw it
as a problem more for white
people than for black people.
Their concern was not
the conditions of blacks,
but what slavery did to whites and usually
they ended up in the same situation
as cold cock Jones.
There are many pro slavery writers who
developed like James Henry Hammond,
what I would call the cynical or a
moral form of pro slavery argument,
and this is a potent form of
argument when you think about it.
Yeah.
One of them was a writer named William
Harper who wrote a book called Memoir of
slavery in 1837 or 38
a. It's an oft quoted work
of pro slavery writing.
This is just one little passage.
This is this kind of cynical,
if you want defense of slavery,
it is what it is, deal with it. He wrote,
man is born to subjection.
The condition of our whole existence
is but to struggle with evil,
to compare them to choose
between them evils that is
and so far as we can to mitigate them.
To say that there is evil
in any institution is only
to say that it is a human
institution. James James, James Jameson,
Harper's writing in the third,
James Henry Hammond starts writing in the
forties and end of the 50 and he takes
that much further and he writes over
and over and over again that the only
problem with slavery in America said,
James Henry Hammond is the too damn many
northerners didn't understand it is the
way of the world as it is and they ought
to stop talking about the world as it
ought to be. In Hammond even aggressively
directly took on Thomas Jefferson.
I'm sorry Harper did even before him.
Here's Harper on Jefferson.
It is not the first time that I've had
occasion to observe that men may repeat
with the utmost confidence,
some maxim or sentimental phrase
as self evident or admitted truth,
which is either palpably false or to
which upon examination it will be found
that they attach no definite idea.
Not withstanding our respect
for the important document,
which declared our independence
yet if anything be found in it,
and especially in what may be regarded
rather as it's ornament than its
substance faults sophistical and,
and meaning that respect should not
screen it from the freest examination.
All men are born free and equal.
He says with a question mark,
is it not palpably near the truth to say
that no man was ever born free and that
no two men were ever born equal?
Man is born in a state of the most
helpless dependence on other people.
Okay.
And then there's the whole vast category
of racial defense and justification of
slavery. At the end of the day,
that's where I was under age.
Stevens went with this cornerstone speech
in 80 61 so all of them went on one
point or another,
some less than others,
probably the most prominent pro-slavery
writer to make the racial case.
And they all did. But probably the
most prominent was George fits you.
Yeah.
In a book called sociology of the South.
He's also the same George Fisher who
wrote a book called cannibals all but in
sociology of the south is famous pro
slave retract and 1854 he wrote this,
the Negro he said is,
but a grownup child and
must be governed as a child.
The master occupies toward him,
the place of parent or Guardian,
like a wild horse.
He must be caught,
tamed and domesticated.
We find slavery repeatedly instituted
by God or by men acting under his
immediate care and direction.
As in the instance of Moses and Joshua,
nowhere in the old or New Testament
do we find the institution condemn but
frequently recognized and enforced.
And probably his most famous line,
men are not born entitled to equal rights.
It would be far and near the truth to say,
and some are born with saddles on their
backs and others booted and spurred to
ride them.
And lastly,
there was a kind of utopian pro slavery.
It was best exemplified by a writer
in Mississippi named Henry Hewes.
Henry, who's was one strange
duck. He lived in New Orleans.
He was eccentric as hell.
He wrote an amazing diary.
He was a loner.
He arres revival of the slave trade in
the late 1850s and he developed a theory
of what he called Warranty Ism.
W.
A. R. R. A. N. T. E. I. S.
M. He said, slaves were not
slaves. They were warranties.
What he meant was they were the charges
put in the world for slave holders to
care for and if possible,
even to protect and perfect.
He believed in a strong central state,
which was a real departure for him from
the rest of the plus pro pro-slavery
writers. He wanted a strong central
government to regulate everything.
He wanted huge taxation.
He wanted to build institutions that
would be used for the sole purpose of
perfecting the slave
into the perfect worker.
He was a bit of a mad scientist
and he was especially obsessed,
was racial purity.
His writings are just replete with his
fears about hygiene that of white and
black people touched or if they came
together, the whites would be soiled
and that any kind of inner mixing of
the races was to destroy ultimately the
intellect, the ability, the
capacity of a master race.
Yeah.
He wasn't that widely read,
I must admit,
but it shows us how far pro
slavery could ultimately
go,
and he uses vision and he, his worldview
slavery was not only a positive good,
okay.
It was the possibility of man finding a
perfected society with the perfect land
owners do fulfilling their
obligations supported by a government,
would tax the hell out of him to do it,
and perfect workers
would make the south and to the
agricultural utopian civilization
of history.
Now,
boxes that run out of timeliness
is leave you with this.
All of that is a way of simply saying
there was a deep and abiding and
well-rehearsed.
Indeed,
thousands of pages were
written in defensive sleep.
It wasn't just the profitable
financial institution.
And if you want to understand
why so many white southerners,
especially in the deep south,
went to such great extents
to save their slave society.
Remember the kinds of arguments
and language used by its defenders.
Thursday we'll take up the north
and the critique of this ideology.